les lions ils ont réagi comme un vrai
[Musique]
lionam la population sénégalaise il le
vio ma fait plaisir mon contô de but
vous savez c'est ça que l'équipe
attendait de moi et je l'ai fait je
pense que j'ai j'ai j'ai j'ai contribué
le dernierre matchétait plutôt les
milieux qu'il avaient marqué j'avais
marqué mais voilà donc plus il y a de
buteurs ça soit des défenseurs des
attaquants c'est c'est bien pour
l'équipe donc voilà on est très
[Musique]
content
les suppors Sénégalais sont très
nombreux on les entend tout le temps sur
le terrain et ça nous donne encore plus
de force ça nous fait très plaisir on a
vu de tris joueurs souvent lever les
bras pour les pour les pour les allumer
un peu et voilà il répondent donc ça
fait ça fait plaisir de les avoir
derrière nous on joue aussi pour eux ils
sont venus pour nous pour nous soutenir
on joue pour leur faire plaisir et pour
le moment ça se passe bien on va
continuer à travailler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]